hey what's up my name is Samuel Lees I'm
a property investor myself and in this
video I'm going to be sharing why
landlords are screwed in
2023. if you are a landlord right now
you're probably quite aware of some of
the changes if you're thinking about
becoming a landlord you need to be aware
of the massive changes that the
government have done recently and the
changes that they are planning to
introduce over the coming months and
years which are completely killing off
landlords and then I'm going to share
some of the things that you can do to
step around the problems because as I
say what are the rich people doing
they're not screwing themselves they're
bringing changes in to screw the
ordinary person so what do you need to
do follow the money and invest out there
investing so I got a little surprise at
the end of the video I'm going to be
doing a giveaway as well so watch till
the end but the first reason why
language and screen is the tax changes
how do the rich usually stop people
doing stuff they don't ban it if the
government said you're not allowed to
buy houses anymore you're not allowed to
own more than one house unless you're an
elite and you're one of us there'd be a
rebellion so what they do instead is
they just attacks the crap out of the
ordinary landlord and that's what
they've done with Section 24. I've been
talking about section 24 for two years
now but people are only realizing what
it is now when they're seeing their tax
returns and they're going what is this
I'll tell you what section 24 is section
24 is when you have to pay tax not on
the profit see it's fair and ordinary
and reasonable for the government to tax
you on profit right if you make profit
you get taxed what they're doing to
landlords is they're taxing landlords on
the whole rent so let me give you an
example if you're renting the property
out for a thousand pounds a month and
your mortgage payments are 500 pounds
that means that your profit is 500
pounds
thousand manage your mortgage payments
gross profit you can pay tax on what
your profit ah not anymore section 24 is
you pay tax on the whole rent you can't
claim back the mortgage payments as tax
deductible so the small rent that you
are making is all going to the
government that is a horrible nasty
brutal thing that I campaigned against
but it's come into full effect people
are realizing it now the second thing is
tenants rights if you're a landlord and
you've got three four five six houses
and you're renting them out if the
tenant stops paying rent in my opinion
you should be able to evict them easily
but the government are changing the
legislation they've done it already
they're going to be scrapping section
21s now if you've got a tenant that's
not paying rent it takes
months to get them out the landlord
wants to just pay has to just pocket the
mortgage payments pocket the maintenance
pocket the management fees out of his
own pocket whilst the tenants living
rent free for six months what it goes to
court
disastrous that is killing landlords
right now the third reason is if it
seems difficult let me explain what this
is epc's difficult energy performance
certificate and this shows how energy
efficient the house is and the lower the
rating the more energy efficient it is
if it's like an A or a b or even a c it
means it's running really energy
efficient and if fail you can't rent a
house out an F it's not energy efficient
enough the government
have recently said that all houses that
are rented out have to be from April
2025 a c now you might think well so
what no no this is going to screw a lot
of landlords imagine you're a landlord
in your own house or you're in three or
four houses and they're in e now you've
got to bring it down to a c how do you
bring it down to a sea
money you've got to do things like maybe
you've got to insulate the roof get
extra double glazing in different parts
of the house you've gotta do that with
what money because you aren't making
money from the rental property anymore
because of the tax changes if the tenant
is in paying and you've had six month
problems you've finally got rid of
you've got another 10 in a lot of
landlords are skins so now they're gonna
have to pay what five thousand pounds
the government aren't paying the
government are enforcing the rule but
the landlord's having to pay so from
April 2025 all buy select properties
have to be a c at the expense of the
landlord next the interest rate Rises on
top of all of this if it couldn't get
any worse interest rates have just
spiked massively meaning that if you've
got a property and you were paying three
or four hundred pounds a month now
interest rates have tripled
I'm not making any profit lose lose lose
every which way and to make things worse
it's not even like your asset is
appreciating value you're a landlord you
just bought three houses got all this
crap all these tax problems interest
rates rise in now you're gonna have to
Shell out more money on EBC but your
house your asset is falling in value
house prices are dropping they keep
every month every month every month
they're falling they're predicted to
fall 10 this year so landlords are
screwed right now in 2023. now what I
want you to do right now because I'm
what I'm doing now is I'm speaking
honestly but I'm also speaking
negatively what I'm speaking now is how
the media will speak but the thing is
this the more that this message is
spread about how difficult it is for
landlords and everyone goes oh it's a
bad time oh don't buy a house I'll sell
my three houses that I had who am I
going to sell them to the rich
Lloyd's Bank who am I going to sell them
to the people that made the rules in the
first place that made me want to sell
now I'm going to sell to them so they're
taking away everything that I've got and
they're making it difficult for the
average person for me and you so why so
that they can have everything but why do
they want everything and a star of
nothing well because they're not
affected by the rules in the same way so
the tax changes for instance section 24
if you buy a house and you're getting
hit with section 24 taxes that's only if
you buy a house you shouldn't buy a
house you should set up a company and
the company should buy the house and
that means that you don't own the house
you own the company and the company owns
the house
why is that important well it protects
you do you know if you have a company
all of the tax stuff I've been talking
about section 24 doesn't apply to a
company why because that's how
they buy properties through companies so
what should you do
buy properties through companies how do
you set your own company up go on
companies Made Simple dot Co dot UK
choose your company name set up a brand
new virgin company right now and then
when you go to buy a house you're going
to be a personal guarantor to the
company so that you'll be able to get a
mortgage but you can still get the same
tax breaks as the Richter The EPC
certificates you should right now like
what they're doing be finding landlords
that have got epce and they're like oh
I'm not making any money I'll find the
rundown houses buy them not with your
own money do you think Lloyds Bank used
their own money
no whose money do they use oh mummy we
put money in the bank they don't keep it
in the bank locked away in a safe damn
that's dead so what you should do is the
same thing you should be using other
people's money and buying properties
with a bad EPC rating buying the rundown
houses and the way that you're going to
pay push the value of the properties is
you're going to fix it you're going to
insulate it you're going to make it nice
and push the value up now you can rent
it out nicely that's what they're doing
you should do what they're doing and
tenant eviction bans I mean listen
there's many ways around the tenant
eviction bans I've got a lot of tenants
I also have a lot of guests see if
you're renting a property out to a
tenant and they don't pay the rent then
you're in a difficult position but if
you're renting your property out to
people on Short Stay lets not only is it
tax efficient not only are you going to
do it through a company not only are you
going to get way more profit like it's
now like a hotel business but also
guests have zero rights which means that
if you're renting your property at Short
Stay let's get way more money paying way
less tax doing it through a company but
if they don't pay the rent they have to
go did I have any rights that's what
wealthy people are doing right now this
is called serviced accommodation or you
can just rent property your properties
out to commercial debits if you've got
hmos or rent them out to people housing
associations whereby you're renting them
out for a high rent but you're not
getting the same problems and same
hassles that you normally have with
tennis I'm not saying you should never
have any tenants but I'm saying that
certainly the bulk of your portfolio
should be guests should be commercial
tenants housing associations you can get
more rent you've got way less so this is
what the rich do and the house price is
falling I mean that again that's just an
opportunity the rich people control the
media control the government and you
might think I sound like an conspiracist
go do your own research they're the ones
spreading the message of how Doom and
Gloom is out there why so the devil's
like oh sell quick sell quick you need
to be strategically buying cheap right
now what everyone's scared pushing the
value up renting properties out the
right way only we're a company and I'll
tell you something you always gotta
follow the money watch what the rich are
doing and go do the sound I think that
now is a terrible time I think it's a
crisis we've got a massive shortage of
houses it is a crisis it is a hard time
but if you can maneuver your way through
it you can get very rich as a property
investor a property owner and a property
entrepreneur in 2023 I'd love to know
your thoughts though if you can't come
up with opportunities in the market if
you think that even though through the
doom and Globe some of the hardships if
you can see opportunities I want you to
comment below all the opportunities that
you can see in the marketplace right now
and this is the gift I'm going to give
you I'm going to be taking the best
comment the most entrepreneurial
creative comment on the pin it to the
top and I'm gonna ask you what's your
phone number and I'm gonna get one of my
mentors to give you a call to put
together an action plan for you to help
you navigate your way through 2023 so
comment below and I'll be pinning and
contacting the best comment
thank you
[Music]